Activités du club
Non
alors pourquoi
Doit être un dandy
Hey allons concourir dans le 50m je l'ai acheté
j'ai entendu quelque chose de bien
8ème place
après
Aujourd'hui c'est le festival et le feu d'artifice au sanctuaire sur ma taille
Les feux d'artifice de Danner ont l'air ronds lorsqu'ils sont vus de côté
Même si tu veux qu'il soit plat, il est toujours rond
moi
Le feu d'artifice d'aujourd'hui vous montre
Allons-y ensemble
si
Si
j'étais cette fois
plus tard
Il est temps pour une blague de cette ville
vous sortez ensemble
Nazuna ne veut pas être emmenée Je suppose que tu n'as pas beaucoup d'amis
C'est le monde que Norimichi-kun a créé, n'existe-t-il pas un tel monde ?
crois que je
Tout est de ma faute
moi
Je veux absolument le reprendre
Même si je fais quelque chose comme ça, c'est impossible, mais je l'ignore
Même si tu es parti
Voyez-vous les feux d'artifice d'en bas ou de côté?